it's about this guy who has powers
shockingly everybody I'm sensing a theme
in this art form just never call it a
hunch
I think there's something going on here
surprise I have powers what's shaking
reject Nations John coming at you joined
by my good friend Olivia what's up
Olivia you can follow her on Instagram
it forever Tiffany's and guess what
olivia is probably a more accomplished
gamer than I am so I asked you on here
to check out this this this this this
this this this this this this new jump
force game you excited yeah that's
exciting actually cuz we just have got
into watching more animes so I'm hoping
to see a couple familiar faces in here
ready to do this let's do this here we
go
really consists of both good and evil
these worlds were never meant to meet
but things have changed they have begun
to okay
Naruto yeah oh damn
whoa
oh this looks so cool
nice
yeah super savers whoa
oh so cool okay all right
[Music]
damn well Death Note a little teaser at
the end that looks sick I mean it's cool
to have all the anime characters
together because I feel like of all the
different types of characters who fight
anime characters cause like the most
high level destruction was just like
charging up power blasts and stuff
[Music]
because this game looks friggin
ridiculous and powers will you have Rock
Lee no I will eventually there's so many
episodes that I'm gonna have to pace
myself or one piece in there it's just
very cool to see all of them converge
into one I feel like this is this is
Capcom versus Marvel but with anime
which I'm surprised hasn't been done
before because this looks very cool it's
something I would love to play oh yeah
there's so many awesome fight scenes in
anime with their own specific art style
that it just makes a ton of sense well
there's so much you can do that's gonna
be cool I hope that's a playable
character that if you beat the game like
a hundred times the flawless score book
and if you have enough time to write
that's the problem is you're gonna have
to like hit so many buttons at once to
do the specific combo that like it'll be
hard to write people's name down but if
you can you know you instantly would see
a lot of people in the comments wishing
that there would be a my hero academia
characters which would be cool I mean
like this almost looks like the fighting
facility they go to Train add just a big
city we're all fighting good stuff it
seemed like there was a kind of a
limited scope of characters that were
showing us in this particular trailer
I'm sure there's gonna be so many
different
personally I'm hoping that maybe one of
the Elric brothers shows up oh because
that would be friggin wicked do an
alchemy in a game like this maybe you
could have hair from bleach in there ooh
yeah which I'm actually surprised they
didn't do cuz that's another really big
animators gonna say I've never seen it
but I know that name yeah I hope that if
Baku go shows up that he screams the
entire game I'm always calm and rational
well guys what did you think of the jump
force reveal trailer hit us up in those
comments leave us your thoughts yell at
us if we missed anything minut and as
always you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get updated everytime a review
is out or a video cuz you know why would
the subscribe button help with that I
don't know it doesn't make any sense hey
check out Olivia on the instagrams
forever Tiffany's and check us out on
patreon - we got all a bunch of cool
stuff over there peace people